I still don't know why celebrities heads
are rocketing into a solar panel but
we'll figure that out later
okay here's how the survey works we ask
three celebrities to complete a phrase
our first phrase was at college parties
I was always the one Seth Rogen said
doing a keg stand while people cheered
Tracee Ellis Ross said tearing up the
dance floor jeff sessions said calling
the cops
now they got some trouble over there got
some drinkers has some smoke or some
smokers and drinkers when I need to
clear my head when I need to clear my
head I Tom Hanks said look at a sunset
Gabrielle Union said take a walk Kim
Kardashian said don't do anything
different
I start my day with speaker Paul Ryan
said a hot cup of black coffee senator
Elizabeth Warren said 15 minutes of
reading briefs and emails Senator John
McCain said a heated argument with my
oatmeal
my favorite thing my favorite thing that
my significant other does is Kumail
Nanjiani said told me she loves me
constantly melissa rauch said listen to
whatever's on my mind Melania Trump said
fill out my time card there were fights
breaking out in the crowd over that one
yeah I liked it I didn't bang I never
leave the house without my Colin Farrell
said Irish pendant Jennifer Aniston said
wedding ring Steven Tyler said
government-issued ID that proves I'm not
a broom
excuse me are you oh I see alright okay
go ahead and under a little more I'll
have to wait yeah chuckles as a child
I'll never forget when my father said to
me Ivana Trump said always work hard
Donald Trump jr. said never appear weak
Tiffani Trump said who are you again
[Applause]
geez it's tough being in a big band
infini in high school I was voted Rachel
McAdams said most likely to succeed
Timothy Olyphant said most likely to be
famous Larry King said most likely to
walk on land and finally he was major
step in evolution thanks to me and
finally when I heard James Comey said he
didn't want to be alone with the
president I thought Mike punch said I
don't like being alone with him and I'm
his vice president Melania Trump said I
don't like being alone with him and I'm
his wife
Bill Cosby said I don't like being alone
with him and I'm Bill Cosby
what I just spent a Nobel Peace Prize
class his TV show award
you